LOOK AT SOME OF THE OPTIONS AND
WE START OFF WITH CHIEF
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS TO TELL US
WHERE THINGS STAND RIGHT NOW.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRETT
AS THE COUNTRIES TRY TO HASH OUT
A DEAL BY FRIDAY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP KEEPING UP THE
POLITICAL PRESSURE ON THEM TO
GIVE HIM BORDER SECURITY AND A
WALL.
THE PRESIDENT WILL BE IN
EL PASO, TEXAS, FOR A BIG
CAMPAIGN-STYLE RALLY AND EARLIER
TODAY AT THE WHITE HOUSE, AN
AFTERNOON MEETING WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
IN A PREDEPARTURE MEETING WITH
LOCAL SHERIFFS, SIX FROM BORDER
STATES, PRESIDENT TRUMP RIPPED
THE DEMOCRATS FOR WANTING TO CUT
THE NUMBER OF SPACES I.C.E. HAS
FOR DETAINING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS, MANY OF THEM
ILLEGALS.
>> NOT ONLY DO THEY WANT TO GIVE
US MONEY FOR THE WALL, THEY
DON'T WANT TO GIVE A SPACE TO
DETAIN MURDERERS, CRIMINALS,
DRUG DEALERS, HUMAN SMUGGLERS.
SPEAK WITH THE PRESIDENT IS OUT
RANGE THAT DEMOCRATIC COUNTRIES
ARE INSISTING ON CUTTING THE
NUMBER OF I.C.E. BEDS TO DETAIN
PEOPLE ALREADY IN THE COUNTRY TO
16,250.
>> DEMOCRATS WANT TO CUT I.C.E.
THEY TAKE OUT MS-13 AND OTHERS
BY THE THOUSANDS AND THEY WANT
TO CUT I.C.E.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO LET THAT
HAPPEN.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP READ NEW
STATISTICS FROM LAST YEAR
SHOWING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WERE
CONVICTED OF 1641 THE HOMICIDES.
NEARLY 1300 KIDNAPPINGS.
ALMOST 4,000 ASSAULTS.
AND NEARLY 30,000 ASSAULTS,
AMONG OTHER CRIMES.
THE PRESIDENT AND SAYS CUTTING
THE NUMBER OF I.C.E. BEDS WOULD
FORCE THE GOVERNMENT TO RELEASE
CRIMINALS INTO SOCIETY.
SHERIFFS AT THE WHITE HOUSE
TODAY SAID THAT WOULD BE A BAD
IDEA.
>> WHAT HAPPENS AT THE BORDER
DOESN'T STAY AT THE BORDER.
IT COMES TO OUR COMMUNITIES IN
NORTH CAROLINA, GEORGIA, OHIO,
UTAH, ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
>> THE DEMOCRATS SAY IT WOULD
FORCE THE ADMINISTRATION TO
FOCUS ON DETAINING AND DEPORTING
CRIMINALS, AND THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE SIMPLY IN THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT BEDS
SUFFICIENT NOT TO DEAL WITH
CRIMINALS, WHICH IS WHAT THE
CASE IS NOW, BUT DEALING WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING, PAYING
TAXES, THEY'LL MAKE IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
>> AS A PRESIDENT HAS TO A
POLITICAL RALLY AT EL PASO, A
WAR OF WORDS WITH EL PASO'S
MAYOR WHO TOOK ISSUE WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S STATE OF THE UNION
CLAIM LAST WEEK.
SPEAK AND CONSIDER ONE OF OUR
NATION'S MOST DANGEROUS CITIES,N
NATION'S MOST DANGEROUS CITIES,W
IMMEDIATELY UPON ITS BUILDING,
WITH A POWERFUL BARRIER IN
PLACE, EL PASO IS ONE OF THE
SAFEST CITIES --
>> CREDITING THEIR SAFETY TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT, NOT A BORDER
WALL.
>> IT'S NOT THE TOTAL PANACEA.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP FOUND HIMSELF
AT ODDS IN LEADERS WITH ANOTHER
STATE, CALIFORNIA LEADER GAVIN
NEWSOM SAYING HE'S GOING TO PULL
BACK THE BULK OF HIS
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS SAYING
HE'S NOT GOING TO ALLOW THEM TO
PURCHASE PAID IN WHAT HE CALLED
"POLITICAL THEATER."
BEFORE HE LEFT THE WHITE HOUSE
THIS AFTERNOON, PRESIDENT TRUMP